أجنبية
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى
] [
موسيقى] أجنبية [موسيقى] أجنبية [
موسيقى]
Yara
um
SUV أجنبية أجنبية [
موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا
أجنبيًا ،
إنه سؤال جيد جدًا لأنه كما
قلت نتحدث عن EV العالمية  المبيعات ولكنها في
الحقيقة تقتصر على عدد صغير
من الأسواق الرئيسية ويتم
تطوير معظمها عند هذا الحد ، لذلك عندما ننظر
إلى الأسواق الناشئة التالية
الجيدة للنمو ،
فإننا ننظر إلى الأسواق التي لها
خصائص مماثلة  إلى دول مثل
الصين والاتحاد الأوروبي ، لذلك نحن نبحث عن تلك
الأسواق التي لديها
سياسة داعمة منسقة جيدة فيما يتعلق بدعم
EVS وما نراه عندما ننظر إلى
الأسواق المختلفة التي نغطيها هو أن
هناك طرقًا مختلفة للقيام بذلك
و  طرق مختلفة
وأولويات مختلفة أيضًا للأسواق المختلفة ،
لذلك نتوقع
نموًا لمدة 30 عامًا خلال العامين المقبلين في
أمريكا اللاتينية من حيث مبيعات السيارات الكهربائية والطريقة التي
يتعاملون بها مع ذلك هي
من خلال وسائل النقل العام ، لذلك لا
يمكن للجميع في هذه الأسواق  تحمل تكاليف EVS
نفسها ، لذلك هناك
خطة منسقة عبر عدد من البلدان في
تلك المنطقة للحافلات الكهربائية ،
لذا فهذه هي الطريقة التي يقتربون
بها إذا نظرنا إلى جنوب شرق آسيا
لأنني أعتقد أنه عندما نتحدث عن
آسيا ، يفكر الناس تلقائيًا في
الصين  كوريا الجنوبية ولكن إذا نظرنا إلى
جنوب شرق آسيا ، تعد تايلاند بالفعل
سوقًا قويًا لإنتاج السيارات ، فإن
الحكومة لديها سجل جيد في
استهداف قطاعات معينة من السيارات من خلال
الاستثمار من أجل مساعدتها على النمو ،
وهي تفعل ذلك الآن بالمركبات الكهربائية
ثم تقدم حوافز
لـ  المستهلكين لشراء هذه
السيارات المنتجة محليًا ،
إذا نظرنا إلى الشرق الأوسط وشمال
إفريقيا ، فالأمر مختلف مرة أخرى لأنه
ليس لديك العديد من
البلدان المصنعة في المنطقة ولكن لديك
جهود تنويع ومشاريع مدينة ذكية
في أسواق مثل دبي والمملكة
العربية السعودية  التي ستؤدي إلى زيادة
الطلب على السيارات الكهربائية ،
تمتلك مصر خطة وطنية لدعم
إنتاج سيارة كهربائية
وأيضًا تحفيز المستهلكين على شراء
السيارات المنتجة محليًا ، لذلك
بدأنا نرى أسواقًا متميزة في
مناطق مختلفة وفي الواقع شيء
اليوم فقط  أخبرني أحد
الزملاء في جنوب إفريقيا أن
إثيوبيا التي لا تتمتع
بمستويات عالية جدًا من ملكية السيارات على الإطلاق
تجعل السيارات الكهربائية أرخص بكثير
في الاستيراد من المركبات الأخرى بحيث
يتنقل الناس إلى الأمام مباشرة إلى
السيارات الكهربائية تمامًا مثل الناس.
فعلته مع الهواتف المحمولة التي تعلم أنها
تخطت
امتلاك خط أرضي تمامًا وذهبت
مباشرة إلى امتلاك هاتف خلوي
وهذا ما نراه مع
السيارات الكهربائية ، لذا بالنسبة للأسواق الناشئة ،
يبدو أن هناك طرقًا مختلفة تمامًا
لكيفية دعمها
هناك الآن  هناك عدد من العوائق التي تحول دون
تبني بعضها يعتمد على السوق ،
لذا لا سيما عندما ننظر إلى
الأسواق الناشئة حيث كنا نتحدث فقط
عن القدرة على تحمل التكاليف ، فهي مشكلة كبيرة ، فأنت
تعلم أن لديك بعض البلدان حيث
لا يفعل المستهلكون ذلك  لديك مستوى
الدخل المطلوب لتحمل هذه الطرز ،
وخاصة في اللحظة التي تعلم فيها أن
لدينا فترة من معدلات الفائدة المرتفعة.
وأيضًا إذا كان سوقًا
لا تمتلك فيه الحكومة
القوة المالية لتقديم الحوافز
وأشكال الدعم الأخرى ، فلا يمكنهم المساعدة في حل
مشكلة
البنية التحتية ،
ونحن نتحدث أولاً عن
نقاط الشحن الفعلية التي تحتوي على ما يكفي من
للتخفيف من بعض القلق من هذا النطاق
ولكن أيضًا مصدر الطاقة الذي تعرفه
أنت في بلد حيث
يكون مصدر الطاقة مستقرًا بما يكفي
لتكون قادرًا على الشحن كما تعلم مرة أخرى
بالتفكير في زملائي في جنوب
إفريقيا لديهم انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وهذا ليس كذلك  مفيد إذا كنت بحاجة إلى شحن
سيارة كهربائية ،
ثم أعتقد أن هناك عاملًا آخر
يساعد المستهلكين على فهم كيف
يمكن أن يصبح هذا جزءًا من حياتهم اليومية ،
كما تعلم إذا كنت معتادًا جدًا على مجرد
الذهاب إلى الغاز
فجأة ، عليك أن تفكر في كيفية
احتواء الشحن في جدولك الزمني ،
لذلك هناك عدد من
الحواجز المختلفة ، لكن يبدو أنها العوائق الرئيسية
الأجنبية
تمامًا كما
قلت إنها
تتجنب عددًا من المشكلات  من حيث
الحصول على قطع الغيار في السوق
ولكنك لن تستفيد من
انخفاض التكاليف
أم معظم
مصانع البطاريات الآسيوية ومعظمها من الصين أه استفاد منها من حيث
تكاليف العمالة من حيث
اقتصاديات الحجم لأننا كنا
نعتمد فقط  على عدد معين من
المنتجين ، وبالتالي كان لديهم نطاق هائل
للاستفادة أيضًا من
um
وأعتقد أن شيئًا آخر يجب أخذه في
الاعتبار هو أنه يعتمد على مقدار
سلسلة إمداد البطاريات التي تقوم بتوطينها
لأنه حتى إذا وجدت
إمدادات من المعادن والمعادن التي
قريبون منك نسبيًا ولديك
تصنيع البطاريات في السوق أو
في المنطقة
في الوقت الحالي ، لا تزال هناك
نسبة كبيرة حقًا أعتقد أننا نتحدث عن
أكثر من 90 في المائة من تكرير
المعادن والمعادن للبطاريات لا
يزال يتم في الصين
نعم ، لذلك ستظل تتحمل
تكاليف الشحن حول
أجزاء مختلفة من البطاريات في أجزاء مختلفة من
العملية إذا لم يتم
تناول ذلك أيضًا ورأينا بعض
التحركات
لإحضار جزء التكرير أه  أكثر محليًا
أيضًا ولكن في الوقت الحالي ،
لا يزال هذا الأمر يعيق الأمور ويضيف إلى
تلك التكاليف أيضًا ، لذلك نعتقد أنك تعلم أننا
نشهد الكثير من الاستثمار في
البطاريات وهذا من شأنه أن يساعد من حيث
وفورات الحجم ولكنه  لا يزال هناك
بضع سنوات قبل أن نبدأ في
رؤيتها تؤتي ثمارها حقًا
[موسيقى]
نعم ، لذا فهذه في الواقع وجهة نظر نشاركها
بأن بعض هذه الأحكام سيكون
لها تأثير سلبي على المبيعات
ويتلخص في الغالب على المستوى المحلي
قواعد المحتوى لذلك من عام 2023 أه 50 من
مكونات البطارية يجب أن تكون محلية في
الولايات المتحدة أو الأسواق التي لديها اتفاقيات تجارة حرة
مع الولايات المتحدة ، ومن هذا
العام رأينا أن الكثير من الطرازات
الكثير من الطرازات غير موجودة  يعد مؤهلاً للحصول على
الإعفاءات الضريبية ، ولذا فأنت تعلم أن ذلك
يضعهم في وضع تنافسي غير مؤاتٍ
من عام 2024 أن
المحتوى المحلي سيرتفع مرة أخرى إلى 60
في المائة ، لذا تعلم أننا كنا نتحدث للتو
عن توطين سلسلة توريد البطاريات
وحقيقة أن ذلك قد
يستغرق  بضع سنوات أخرى لنكون نشيطين بشكل كامل ، لذلك
قد نرى المزيد من النماذج تصبح
غير مؤهلة في العام المقبل ،
لذلك نحن
في الأساس في وقت غير مؤهل حقًا
أعتقد بالنسبة للمستهلكين ،
ما لم يكونوا مواكبين حقًا
للمحتوى المحلي لـ  السيارات التي يرغبون
في شرائها
لا يعرفون النماذج
المؤهلة في أي وقت وحتى
يبدؤون في إجراء بحث عن ذلك ،
هناك أيضًا حقيقة أن الأسعار
تتقلب كثيرًا في الولايات المتحدة في
الوقت الحالي ، كان هناك الكثير من الأخبار  حول
Tesla وتخفيضات أسعارها ، لكنك
تعلم أيضًا أنها تقوم بتعديل
بعض الأسعار لأعلى في بعض الطرز
أيضًا ، لذلك هناك الكثير من الصعود والهبوط
ولا يعرف المستهلكون حقًا ما
تعرفه من أسبوع إلى
آخر في بعض الحالات  ما هي الأسعار التي ستكون
مثل العلامات التجارية الأخرى التي ستحذو
حذوها أحيانًا
حتى نتمكن من رؤية أن
التأثير السلبي أيضًا على الأسعار وعلى
المستهلكين غير متأكدين حقًا
من كيف ستكون الأشياء
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
نعم ،  نعلم في الخلفية أن الكثير
من الشركات المصنعة تعمل على
بطاريات الحالة الصلبة والتي يُنظر إليها على
أنها بديل إيجابي حقًا في
حقيقة أنها ستكون أكثر استقرارًا
وأمانًا لأننا واجهنا مشكلات مع
حرائق السيارات بالسيارات الكهربائية ولكن في
الواقع  من حيث شيء جاهز
للدخول إلى السوق من شأنه أن يحدث
فرقًا حقيقيًا ، فإن سيارة النورس التي تعد
ميزانيتها تستخدم بطاريات أيون الصوديوم
بدلاً من أيونات الليثيوم
والتي لها عدد من الفوائد ،
فهي جيدة جدًا من حيث كثافة الطاقة.
على قدم المساواة مع LSP ،
بطارية ليثيوم أيون فوسفات من حيث
كثافة الطاقة ولكن الصوديوم
أكثر وفرة من الليثيوم ، لذلك
لا توجد مخاوف كثيرة بشأن الإمدادات
بشأن وجود إمدادات كافية وهي
أيضًا إيجابية من حيث التكلفة وأنت
تعلم  لهذا السبب يمكنهم بدء هذا
العرض بسعر 11 ألف
دولار وسيكون لذلك
تأثير إيجابي حقيقي من حيث جذب
المزيد من الأشخاص إلى سوق السيارات الكهربائية مع المزيد من
النماذج ذات الأسعار المعقولة التي تحدثت عن
القدرة على تحمل التكاليف كونها مشكلة في وقت سابق.
في الواقع أفضل بكثير مما لو
نظرت إلى أوراق نيسان الأولى ، على سبيل
المثال التي كانت في السوق ،
ربما كنت تحصل على 100 ميل كحد أقصى الآن
المتوسط ​​هو حوالي 200 ميل أي
حوالي 320 كيلومترًا ،
بعض من أبعدها سيكون 300
ميل
وما يعنيه ذلك هو أنه يمكنك بشكل أساسي
تغطية الكثير من حالات الاستخدام للسيارات الكهربائية التي
تعرف أننا اعتدنا التحدث
عنها دائمًا على أنها رائعة
للرحلات القصيرة في المدينة الداخلية ولكن ليس كثيرًا
للمسافات الطويلة أو
الكثير من الاستخدام في  اليوم ولكن الآن إذا
كنت تتحدث عن مائتي ميل أو
ثلاثمائة ميل في الحالة القصوى ،
فأنت تتحدث أكثر عن الأشخاص الذين
يرغبون في القيام برحلات طويلة أو الذين يتعين عليهم
القيام بالكثير من الرحلات في اليوم إذا كان ذلك
جزءًا من  لقد
كان ذلك بمثابة تحسين حقيقي ،
كما أننا نسمع عن
بدائل للشحن مثل تبديل البطارية ،
تحدثت نيو حديثًا عن
العلامة التجارية الصينية Neo التي تحدثت عن شعبية
محطات تبديل البطاريات الخاصة بها لأنها
تتيح للأشخاص الحصول على الجديد
البطارية أسرع بكثير مما لو كانوا
ينتظرون الشحن ، وهذا أيضًا
بديل آخر يعالج قلق النطاق ،
ولكن فيما يتعلق بالبطاريات
نفسها ، لدينا تنوع أكبر بكثير
من حيث كيميائية البطارية ،
وأحجام البطارية وهذا يعني أنه يمكنك
حقًا اختيار شيء ما  الذي يلبي
حالة الاستخدام الخاصة بك
من حيث سعة البطارية ، أود أن
أقول إن لدينا مخاوف أقل ،
كما ذكرت سابقًا ، فأنت تعلم أننا
رأينا مليارات اليورو والدولارات
تُستثمر في تصنيع البطاريات
وهذا ليس فقط من قبل مصنعي البطاريات.  لقد
تواجدوا تقليديًا في
الفضاء ولكن أيضًا صانعي السيارات أنفسهم
وأصبحوا أكثر انخراطًا في
سلسلة توريد البطاريات والشيء الذي يتعلق بمشاركتهم
هو أنهم يعرفون عدد ما
يحتاجون إليه ،
لذا فهم يعملون نحو
أهدافهم الخاصة وفي بعض الحالات
هناك صانعو سيارات يتطلعون
إلى تزويد الشركات الأخرى أيضًا ، لذا فقد
قاموا ببناء ذلك في
السعة المقصودة لهذه المصانع ، لذلك
لن نكون قلقين للغاية بشأن
جانب سعة البطارية للأشياء ولكن بالتأكيد على
جانب المعادن والمعادن نحن  العمل عن كثب
مع
محللي المعادن والتعدين لدينا باستخدام توقعاتهم
للإنتاج والنظر في الاحتياطيات
والنيكل على وجه الخصوص ، فأنت تعلم أنهم
يقولون على المدى القصير إلى المتوسط
وليس مشكلة كبيرة من
حوالي عام 2028 على الرغم من أنهم يتوقعون ذلك  نرى
السوق في حالة عجز ، لذلك
يمكننا أن نرى المشاكل لأنه لا
تزال هناك كيميائيات للبطاريات
تحظى بشعبية كبيرة والتي تحتوي على نسبة عالية من
النيكل خاصةً بالنسبة إلى المزيد من
الطرز المتميزة ، لذا سيكون هذا شيئًا يجب
البحث عنه في هذا الجانب
من الليثيوم الذي يتوقعونه  انظر إلى
نشاط الاستكشاف المستمر الذي يدعم
الإنتاج
هناك حتى تعرف أننا نسمع عن وجود
مخاوف بشأن الليثيوم ولكن في
نفس الوقت يولد الاستكشاف
ويتحدثون أيضًا عن
التقنيات الجديدة والمعدات الجديدة التي
تجعلها في الواقع أكثر كفاءة
لذلك  الجانب الإيجابي لذلك ، لكننا
سمعنا مؤخرًا عن
الاكتشافات الجديدة لاحتياطيات الليثيوم في الهند
على سبيل المثال ، لذا من المشجع أيضًا
أنه على جانب الليثيوم
للأشياء قد لا يكون سيئًا للغاية ،
إنه بالتأكيد أفضل مما كان عليه ولكن
أعتقد أننا  لا يزال بإمكانك فعل المزيد إذا كنت
تعرف مجرد التفكير هنا في
المملكة المتحدة فقط إذا كنت تفكر في عدد محطات الوقود ، فما
زلنا لسنا عند هذا المستوى حتى الآن بالنسبة
لنقاط شحن المركبات الكهربائية على الرغم من أن الإيجابي هو
أنك تراها في أماكن مختلفة
إلى محطات الوقود التقليدية حتى
تراها في متنزهات المكاتب تراها في
مراكز التسوق أم حتى يمكن وضعها في
أماكن مختلفة
ولكن أعتقد أنه بناءً على مستويات
التبني التي نتوقع رؤيتها لا
يزال هناك الكثير الذي يمكن تحقيقه  تم القيام به
وحتى في أسواق مثل الاتحاد الأوروبي حيث
يوجد الكثير من الدعم لمشروعات um green
بشكل عام ، لا يزال هناك المزيد
الذي يمكن القيام به في الكثير من البلدان ، ومن
بين المشكلات التي تحدثنا عنها دائمًا
أننا تحدثنا دائمًا عن من
يتساءل  من المسؤول هو
صانعو السيارات ، هل هي المرافق ،
الحكومات ، لذا فأنت تحتاج حقًا إلى شخص ما
ليقود من حيث تحديد من
سيفعل ذلك ، وفي بعض الأحيان ، وخاصة
في الأسواق المتقدمة ، نرى
مزيجًا نرى بعض الشحن  النقاط
التي يتم تشغيلها من قبل صانعي السيارات وبعضها
من خلال المرافق وأعتقد أن
المرافق العامة
أصبحت تشارك أكثر فأكثر لأنهم
يرون أن هذا قد يكون له تأثيرات غير مباشرة
على الشبكة
التي تعرفها خاصة إذا كانت
السيارات الكهربائية يمكن أن تبدأ في التغذية مرة أخرى
الشبكة وكذلك
شركات النفط كما تعلمون
جميع الشركات التي تمتلك بعض محطات الوقود هذه
تشارك أيضًا ،
وهذا أمر إيجابي ولكن أعتقد أنه لا
يزال هناك الكثير للقيام به
[موسيقى] أجنبية